olivier hudon senti bonjour et merci de
nous recevoir au conservatoire de
plaisir où vous enseignez vous enseigne
dans plusieurs plusieurs classes a donc
oui j'enseigne essentiellement dans la
case accordéon j'ai un cordon de
concerts l'accordéon donc qui joue le
répertoire classique et aussi
contemporain et je me balade aussi au
sein des classes de formation musicale
pour faire un éveil au à la création à
l'improvisation générative donc ça c'est
auprès des enfants du deuxième cycle et
puis nous mettons en place avec
divergent à ce moment-là divers
instruments et complètement ils jouent
ensemble et un travail de création à
partir de l'oreille à partir de lait
coûte ensemble improvisations dirigées
je met au piano ou à l'accordéon et il
joue ensemble on écoute des choses aussi
on les analyse
et puis et puis l'atelier donc tango qui
se met en place cette année puisque je
me suis moi même mis au bandonéon j'ai
envie de partager cette passion la
musique est un instrument aussi
formidable fait partie de la famille des
accordéons des accords de
deux concerts et autres alors on va
parler mais justement vous même vous
avez été un des premiers bénéficiaires
de 7 ans et non classique je veux dire
de l'accordéon complètement je pense que
mes professeurs était la toute première
génération
à enseigner l'accordéon officiellement
dans les conservatoires juin
personnellement de l'académie de musique
massereene et 3 monaco christian bonnet
mon professeur voilà on était nous les
les premiers la principauté oui à
bénéficier de cette vision de
l'accordéon et pourquoi vous avez choisi
cet instrument et je pense qu'après
avoir fait le tour pendant deux ans on
découverte instrumentale piano violon je
suis un petit peu dit beaucoup moins
oui un désir de régime je pense et j'ai
été surpris au premier coup on va
montrer l'accordéon il ya un grand et
lèvent déjà qui jouer avec des registres
une fut prof de bach et ça m'a ému en
fait j'avais donc sept ans et demi et
j'étais presque pris aux larmes en fait
d'entendre cette musique par cet
instrument est bon là j'ai su que
c'était un travail à partager à partager
cette surprise et mais c'était ça qui se
faisait marrer comment ça se fait qu'en
france enfin l'accordéon voilà on
connaît la corde aux musiques populaires
quoi
j'avais un peu moins la corde et non de
les dire classique ou ne sais pas si
c'est le terme un peu moins allant
chercher la surprise
très agréable de remarquer que sur des
ondes à la radio on a de plus en plus de
d'accord de liste jason dans le milieu
contemporain on parlait de max bonnet
qui dirige la classe internationale peur
de musique de paris ne passe qu'à
compter aussi j'ai qui joue souvent
règle intercontemporain
comme le programme sur france musique
qui souvent partenariat avec les
homologues européens ont peu envie
d'entendre un grand accordéoniste de
rentrer lotis par exemple et qui a joué
avec l'intercontemporain rossi qui a
fait des cra à suivre avec le père c'est
vrai que c'est en train de voir ça je
pense qu'au niveau des années mais c'est
la télévision peut être un petit peu
plus en retard de ce point de vue là
mais dans l'esprit peut-être de voilà
donc dans l'esprit des gens c'est
qu'obama est d'abord peut-être
mais on le défend bien la corne
traditionnelle avec des personnalités
comme yann tiersen oui pour le jazz on a
bien sûr ludovic beier et richard
galliano il a avec grammophon a fait a
fait avancer au niveau du grand public
la vision de l'accordéon bus qu'il
enregistrait bac finalement macaques à
longue queue quelque chose bien entendu
qu'on conservatoire oui on a tiqué déjà
des
bougies
mais avec richard kind grammophon c'est
peut être une portée et notre portée de
parole parce que ben voilà le disque
bénéficie d'une promotion d'une
couverture que peut-être et c'est vrai
que ça fait découvrir aussi enfin c'est
déjà un premier pas de découvrir cet
instrument d'une dune avec une autre
image que celui qui l'avait traditionnel
pourquoi et moi je tiens à dire souvent
que c'est vrai que l'on a tenté nous les
accordéonistes met vraiment l'accent sur
le développement de l'accordéon la
grande et on aujourd'hui contemporain
l'accordéon qui joue un répertoire
baroque qui joue dans les orchestres
mais on peut être fier en france d'abord
cette richesse avoir oublié d'avoir des
grands artistes au niveau de la musique
traditionnelle
qui
ce qui montre à quel point on est on est
un pays ouvert
ça je crois que c'est important que
notre génération ne l'oublient pas non
plus le répertoire alors parlé de bac
bac a écrit précisément pour l'accordéon
cdc des
adaptations vendéen alors on se permet
aisément la transcription parce que je
ne vois pas très compliqué donc voilà en
fait elle il n'y a quasiment pas de
transcription sert qu'on lit on a un
clavier sauf qu'il est répartie de façon
différente par rapport aux classes 1 ou
à l'orgue
mais on a un clavier complet équivalent
qui ne trahit pas la pensée mathématique
hamonic de jean sébastien bach donc
suffit de poser des doigts ou la
partition nous demande de jouer et
fidèlement respecte fidèlement à
prêcher à chaque fois et très
précisément respecté
par rapport au texte original et à ce
titre là je pense qu'on ya une
légitimité à faire découvrir le
répertoire pour clavier oui on sait que
jean sébastien bach lui-même transcrivez
bas il écrit n'est pas non plus pour les
instruments avec lesquels on joue
aujourd'hui donc je pense que ça on peut
même au niveau de la recherche
musicologique
poussé certaines réflexions sur le
phrasé sur la résonance sur le mélange
des harmoniques jeu
avec le clavier accordéon qui peut tenir
les sont contraints au clavecin ou qui
pose comme l'orgue de tenir les sons
mais développer ou l'expression de la
nuance de la dynamique alors donc il ya
évidemment les musiciens classiques et
puis il ya alors j'ai presque une
explosion mais c'est vrai enfin avec la
musique contemporaine
et surtout je pense les grands ensembles
oui moi personnellement à travers les
expériences que j'ai depuis une dizaine
d'années avec l' orchestre
philharmonique de radio france hors
caisse nationale de france l opéra de
paris on se rend compte quasiment chaque
année
lorsqu'il ya une commande qui est passé
un auditeur d'aujourd'hui il ya il ne
résiste pas à la tentation de rajouter à
son à sa palette de toul orchestre a
ajouté cet ingrédient de l'accordéon
d'aujourd'hui et passe à sa place est le
fruit de toute une génération qui
oeuvrent dans les conservatoires dans
les festivals dans les concours
à faire connaître qui veut y vont vers
fait ça on ne donnait presque des cours
en nous disant voilà comment il faut
aller vers un g10 est ce qu'il faut le
dire pour l'enthousiasmé pour lui donner
des clés pour qui les crimes au départ
peut-être pour accordéon et violoncelle
accordéon et clarinette accordéon violon
et puis peut-être accordéon et quatuor à
cordes
puisque c'est d'abord des taux si elle
est souvent qui se marie avec très bien
avec tous les autres avant de
parfaitement bien on se rend compte que
c'est un parfait relais entre les
percussions
pour sos son timbre parfois à sec les
geeks quoi les hanches libre et en même
temps les cordes il peut y avoir un
velouté dans la résonance dans la tenue
les voies
on se rend compte que souvent dans les
opéras il ya où le coup le coeur nous
sollicitent j'ai fait récemment la messe
solennelle de rossini
qui a été écrite aussi en partie pour
piano harmonium et coeur et là on se
rend compte ça voilà ça se marier très
très bien on accompagne les chanteurs
aiment être accompagné par l'accordéon
parce qu'ils ont l'impression d'être
portés d'être d'avoir aussi
l'accompagnement la justesse de la note
mais l'expression l'expression de leur
caisse le phrasé de la voix c'est une
palette extrêmement l'âge alors je
reviens vers vous vous avez eu beaucoup
de premiers prix 1
et puis voilà vous grâce à cet
instrument c'est vous faites beaucoup de
choses des musiques contemporaines
évidemment pas qu'on en parle et vous
êtes allés aussi avec zazie vert vers
l'avenir la variété oui enfin vous vous
ouvrez totalement votre palette parce
que c'est un instrument qui permet tout
ça ah oui alors ce qui est un téléphone
dans le par exemple prenons le cas de
zazie c'est que zazie m'a pas demandé de
faire à la avec cet accordéon moderne de
faire de la variété oui non c'est un
artiste donc qu'il est très engagé enfin
selon moi dans la pop music loisirs la
musique voilà et qui a fallu rajouter
c'est selon - cet ingrédient d'accordéon
et évolue évoluer ou dans cette
évolution et lorsqu'on écoute
attentivement donc le titre 1-2 qui est
sur l'album amazon on se rend compte que
la facture est plus proche du tango très
moderne
de la musique presque parfois
contemporaine mais
il oublie parce que c'est excitant c'est
que les mêmes la collaboration avec un
artiste de variétés ou de pop music ll
l'instrument a amené était attractif et
a inspiré tout le monde à venir sur ce
terrain là on s'est pris à lui plutôt
que lui est il
pour quelque chose et après c'est vrai
que il ya encore énormément de choses à
faire je parlais récemment de
développement de l'accordéon numérique
c'est vrai qu'en numérisant le souffle
et ça en donnant puisque les ports de
porter quelque chose lui complètement
moi je pense que par rapport au clavier
on développe énormément les claviers les
synthétiseurs les claviers m mais que
avec l'expression au souffle et
la l'électronique peut développer
quelque chose dans le phrasé dans le
phrasé classique dans la finesse dans la
finesse de jeu est-ce que les
techniquement question un peu mais aussi
est-ce que les touches
donne quelque chose de différent que
enfin que les que les touches d'un piano
alors oui ça c'est une question
intéressante il faut savoir que la
dynamique c'est-à-dire la nuance de
jouer piano très doux au contraire très
fort ne se fait pas par l' attaque du
bouton
cantonnés sur un accord non acoustique
par contre c'est vrai que sur
l'accordéon numérique oui on comprend
voie forçant de la force donc la tacc de
la touche on va avoir une palette
une palette de nuances combinée à la
palette de nuances du soufflet qui est
lui-même numérisés et donc la voilà un
mode de jeu mais c'est vrai que
l'excitation du son pour l'accordéon
acoustique se fait par le soufflé alors
je dis voilà vous avez pleuré à peu près
tout les toutes les possibilités
d'assurer aussi la musique de film
évidemment la musique de film c'était
afin à travers cette rencontre avec
anissa qui pour les lettres à un jeune
poète
où on a travaillé plutôt sur le centre
design sur le bruitage sur la dimension
poétique qui peut y avoir à travailler
le a priori les climats sonores et puis
voilà on a fait d'autres pièces de
théâtre et puis lui-même est venu vers
moi pour faire des expériences sonores à
travers voilà le film le candidat et ont
je pense que on a pu aller assez loin
malgré le sujet qui est un sujet assez
voilà academy voilà grâce à vous on
découvre à ses instruments pour croyez
connaître au fond le connais pas encore
très bien que d'être un peu grâce à vous
c'est beaucoup d'honneur moi je veux
c'est à dire que on est une génération
on avance grâce à parce que on peut être
fier de nos institutions qui depuis les
années 80 essayait vraiment de mettre en
place deux partout sur le territoire une
vision exigeante de l'accordéon donc
dans n'importe quelle petite ville a
priori
on a un souci de faire connaître aux
populations l'accordéon deux concerts
donc je suis heureusement pas le seul de
nos
nazis ci a eu un passé merci beaucoup
des vidéos sens dit merci